Traduttore: Raffaele Gaito
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Binge watching.
Quanti di voi sanno cosa significa
questa parola? Alzate la mano.
Quanti di voi hanno fatto,
almeno una volta nella vita,
binge watching?
Ora lo spiego anche agli altri.
Binge watching è un termine
nato abbastanza recentemente
che indica l'attività di guardare
una puntata dietro l'altra
di una serie tv,
senza interrompersi mai.
Per capirci - quelli che hanno
alzato la mano lo sanno,
è la classica maratona da divano.
Ci mettiamo lì, guardiamo un episodio,
poi un altro ancora, poi un altro ancora,
e non ci fermiamo mai.
Oggi, grazie a strumenti
come Netflix e tanti altri, infatti,
è cambiato il modo con il quale
usufruiamo dei prodotti seriali,
le serie tv o di altro tipo.
Ora non dobbiamo più aspettare
una settimana, come succedeva prima,
per un nuovo episodio.
Ce li abbiamo tutti lì!
Ne vogliamo guardare uno?
Un altro ancora?
Sono tutti a portata di un click
sul nostro telecomando.
E se ci pensate,
qualcosa di molto simile
capita anche con gli oggetti,
grazie a strumenti come Amazon Prime.
Di cosa avete bisogno?
Di un libro? Di un paio di scarpe?
Di un accessorio
per il vostro smartphone?
Di qualsiasi cosa voi abbiate bisogno,
potete ottenerla il giorno dopo,
o in alcune città
addirittura dopo poche ore.
Ancora una volta,
tutto lì, a portata di un click -
sul nostro smartphone, in questo caso.
E vogliamo parlare del cibo?
Cosa volete mangiare stasera?
Avete voglia di pizza,
preferite pizza, sushi,
volete un hamburger?
Volete mangiare pasta, carne?
Dovete solo scegliere!
Avete tutto a portata di un click
sul vostro smartphone,
grazie a strumenti come JustEat.
E che dire del sesso?
Volete saltare la trafila
di uscite imbarazzanti,
di serate dove non sapete cosa dire,
dei due di picche imprevisti?
Oggi si può!
Ancora una volta,
abbiamo tutto li a portata di un click
sul nostro smartphone,
con strumenti come Tinder.
Penso che uno degli impatti più grossi
che abbia avuto il digitale
e la tecnologia in generale
sulla nostra vita,
specie negli ultimi anni,
è in termini di velocità.
La velocità con la quale
riusciamo ad ottenere le cose.
Questi che vi ho mostrato, Tinder, ecc.
sono solo alcuni dei tanti strumenti,
applicazioni, sistemi, aziende
che hanno letteralmente abbattuto
le barriere tra noi e i nostri desideri.
Barriere in termini di spazio,
ma barriere soprattutto
in termini di tempo.
Io più penso a questa cosa
e più credo che stiamo vivendo
l'epoca del "tutto e subito".
Ci stiamo abituando
ad aprire lo smartphone,
c'è un'app e possiamo ottenere una cosa.
Stiamo iniziando a dare per scontato
questa cosa del tutto e subito.
Gli americani, che ovviamente
hanno un nome per qualsiasi cosa,
chiamano questa tendenza
che abbiamo negli ultimi anni
col nome di "instant gratification",
che significa gratificazione instantanea.
Se non avete mai sentito questo termine,
ve lo faccio capire un esempio:
la doppia spunta blu di Whatsapp.
(Risate)
E tutte le problematiche
che ha introdotto questa singola novità.
Ditemi che non è mai capitato,
a qualcuno di voi,
di guardare il vostro smarphone,
in particolare Whatsapp,
aprire una chat,
e pensare o dire la frase
"ha visualizzato, ma non ha risposto".
Con tutte le conseguenze
che questa frase porta nella nostra mente.
In termini di arrabbiature,
di congetture, di pensieri,
di incazzature che ci facciamo
solo perché qualcuno
ha visualizzato, ma non ha risposto.
Credo che col digitale
stia succedendo una cosa:
stiamo iniziando a confondere
la velocità del mezzo
con la velocità del fine.
E questa cosa è terribile,
perché ci sta dando, dentro di noi
una sottile illusione di successo,
come se grazie al digitale
il successo fosse alla portata di tutti.
Come se fosse quasi dovuto,
e veloce, e rapido - immediato.
Ma questa è solamente un illusione.
Ci siamo circondati di metriche di vanità
per alimentare questa illusione.
E quindi viviamo l'epoca
nella quale contiamo i like,
contiamo le condivisioni,
contiamo i retweet, contiamo i follower.
In un momento qualsiasi
uno di voi può aprire lo smartphone,
condividere qualcosa
su uno dei social media
e avere un risultato immediato.
Avere un riscontro immediato,
avere quella gratificazione istantanea
di cui vi parlavo prima.
E paradossalmente,
quando non ce l'abbiamo
iniziamo ad arrovellarci
su cosa è andato storto.
E quindi,
Perché sto facendo così pochi like?
Perché nessuno sta commentando?
O peggio ancora,
perché quella persona
mi ha tolto il follow
o non è più mio amico?
Sapete qual è la cosa più assurda,
di questa faccenda?
Il nostro cervello,
quando si trova in questa situazione
di gratificazione istantanea,
è stato provato che produce
una sostanza che si chiama dopamina.
La dopamina ci fa stare bene,
ci da una bella sensazione,
quindi più ne produciamo
e più ne vogliamo.
Se non avete mai sentito
parlare della dopamina,
è la stessa sostanza
che viene prodotta
quando fumiamo, quando beviamo alcol,
quando scommettiamo -
tutte cose che hanno
una caratteristica in comune:
creano dipendenza.
E questa illusione di successo,
lentamente credo che sia
un po' alimentata
anche dai media, negli ultimi anni,
con il racconto continuo
di storie, di persone, di ragazzi
che grazie al digitale sono arrivati
al successo molto velocemente.
Sono diventati ricchi fin da giovani.
Questo è uno dei tanti:
la storia di Mark Zuckerberg,
il fondatore di Facebook,
penso la conosciamo tutti quanti,
non devo raccontarvela io.
Ma lui è solo uno dei tanti!
Lui è Evan Spiegel,
il fondatore di Snapchat
con una storia molto simile
a quella di Mark.
O ancora Kevin Systrom,
il fondatore di Instagram:
ancora una volta,
una storia molto simile
ai due precedenti.
Oppure, se vogliamo prendere
un esempio tutto nostrano, italiano,
la fashion blogger più famosa del mondo,
la nostra Chiara Ferragni.
Storie di questo tipo non sono più
solo nei media di settore,
come in passato.
Ormai sono ovunque.
Diventando molto spesso
dei punti di riferimento,
se non addirittura un metro di paragone,
soprattutto per i più giovani,
soprattutto per i ragazzi.
E voi a questo punto potreste dirmi
che 'sta roba non vi riguarda,
non vi tocca, voi siete diversi.
Tutto questo che ho detto
a voi non vi tocca.
E potrebbe essere così,
magari avete ragione.
Però potrebbe riguardare
i vostri fratelli, le vostre sorelle,
potrebbe riguardare
i vostri figli, i vostri nipoti.
Ci sono studi scientifici,
soprattutto negli USA, negli ultimi anni,
che hanno dimostrato che questa tendenza
alla gratificazione istantanea,
al tutto e subito
sta avendo un impatto devastante
sui giovanissimi!
Sulle nuove generazioni,
dai millennials in poi,
sta avendo un impatto devastante.
Le nuove generazioni,
i ragazzi i giovanissimi,
hanno sempre meno autostima,
un senso di insoddisfazione perenne,
di inadeguatezza perenne.
Una mancanza di fiducia
nella vita privata,
ma soprattutto in quella lavorativa,
visto che è di quello
che stiamo parlando oggi.
Questo ne è solo un esempio.
Non so se avete mai visto questa ragazza.
Lei si chiama Lisette,
ed è salita alla ribalta della cronaca,
qualche mese fa, per una storia surreale.
Lei si era appena trasferita a New York,
e si è letteralmente riempita di debiti,
in pochissimo tempo,
per comprare cose,
oggetti, vestiti, gioielli
solo per poterli mostrare
nelle sue foto su Instagram.
Una storia surreale!
Lo ripeto: si è riempita di debiti
per comprare oggetti da mostrare
nelle sue foto su Instagram.
Perché lei si era trasferita a New York,
e quindi voleva vivere una vita da star.
Anzi, oggi diremmo una vita da influencer.
Poco importa che in realtà
aveva messo in piedi una farsa,
perché quella vita non le apparteneva.
Anzi, paradossalmente lei non poteva
nemmeno permettersela: non aveva i soldi.
Ma non le interessava!
No, perché lei voleva il tutto e subito.
Voleva il risultato immediato,
voleva la gratificazione istantanea
di cui parlavo prima.
Sapete cosa credo?
Credo che un po' alla volta
stiamo perdendo l'uso della pazienza.
Stiamo iniziando a dare per scontato
questo tutto e subito,
e stiamo anche diventando dipendenti
da questa gratificazione istantanea -
o istant gratification,
come la chiamano gli americani.
Ma non confondetemi:
quando parlo di pazienza,
la pazienza non ha nulla a che fare
con la lentezza, con l'immobilità.
La pazienza per come la vedo io è visione.
È il riuscire a investire
nel lungo periodo.
Darsi degli obiettivi nel lungo periodo.
Non so se avete mai sentito
il famoso discorso
di Steve Jobs a Stanford.
Lui fa una metafora bellissima e dice:
"Nella vita non puoi unire i puntini
guardando in avanti.
Li puoi unire solo guardando indietro.
Però a un certo punto
devi avere fiducia
che potrai fermarti, girarti indietro
e unire questi puntini."
Ecco perché è fondamentale
tenere in considerazione
la parte attiva della pazienza,
che è la costanza!
Mentre la parte passiva è la pigrizia.
La pazienza non è semplicemente
il sapere aspettare,
ma è cosa facciamo mentre aspettiamo.
È lì la differenza.
E allora forse dovremmo raccontare
più storie di costanza.
Dovremmo raccontare di come
questo signore alle mie spalle,
che si chiama Jack Ma,
il fondatore di AliBaba,
è stato rifiutato 10 volte ad Harvard
prima di fondare la sua azienda, AliBaba,
e poi diventare
l'uomo più ricco della Cina.
Oppure raccontare di come questo signore,
che si chiama Peter Vesterbacka,
fondatore di Rovio,
aveva lanciato 51 giochi senza successo,
la sua azienda era vicina al fallimento.
E poi ha ideato Angry Birds,
che è diventato uno dei giochi
più famosi della storia.
Oppure raccontare di come Brian Acton,
quest'altro signore alle mie spalle,
il fondatore di Whatsapp,
quando cercava lavoro è stato rifiutato
prima da Facebook e poi da Twitter.
Poi decise di fondare
la sua azienda, Whatsapp,
e l'ha venduta proprio
a Facebook, per 19 miliardi.
O raccontare di come Leah Busque,
la fondatrice di TaskRabbit,
abbia dovuto cambiare il business model
della sua azienda decine di volte,
litigare con gli utenti inferociti,
col CdA, dimettersi da CEO dell'azienda
ma poi, alla fine,
riuscire a vendere la sua azienda a IKEA
e rivoluzionare un settore intero.
Cosa hanno in comune
queste quattro storie?
Due cose:
il focus su un'obiettivo
e l'amore per il processo.
Perché io credo che la differenza,
in fin dei conti sia veramente lì.
Nell'amare il processo, quello che fai,
nell'innamorarsi del processo.
Per capirci,
il processo è la parte concreta,
è la parte attiva, quotidiana,
operativa della pazienza.
Il processo molto spesso
è già il risultato.
Il processo sono i piccoli step
che giorno dopo giorno
ci portano al risultato.
Il processo sono i puntini
di cui parlava Steve Jobs.
Volevo condividere con voi
quattro motivazioni -
ho scritto quattro vantaggi -
per le quali, secondo me,
dovremmo riappropriarci
di questa capacità perduta,
di questa pazienza.
Perché recuperare la pazienza?
Secondo me le motivazioni sono tante,
ma ho provato ad elencarne quattro.
La tolleranza.
La pazienza ci rende tolleranti
verso gli errori.
Verso gli errori degli altri,
ma soprattutto verso i nostri.
Ed errore dopo errore,
noi non abbiamo solamente più esperienza
ma diventiamo anche più resilienti.
E ricordiamoci
che il famoso processo
di cui parlavo prima
non deve andare per forza
in una sola direzione.
A un certo punto dobbiamo avere
anche la forza e il coraggio
di ammettere a noi stessi
che stiamo sbagliando, e cambiare rotta.
Il secondo è il tempo.
La pazienza è l'unico modo che abbiamo
per recuperare il tempo.
Che è una cosa sulla quale
stiamo perdendo il controllo,
negli ultimi anni.
E in realtà è una cosa
strettamente collegata
con la nostra salute mentale,
e quindi con la nostra felicità.
Le decisioni.
La pazienza è l'unica arma che abbiamo
per prendere decisioni ponderate.
Per avere il focus sul presente,
ragazzi, sul momento attuale.
Per riuscire a valutarlo,
e in base a quello prendere una decisione.
Volete migliorare le vostre
performance di business?
Iniziate da questo!
E il quarto e ultimo:
la pazienza è necessaria per imparare.
Per ammettere a noi stessi
che non sappiamo tutto,
che non conosciamo tutto
e a volte dobbiamo darci
il tempo di imparare le cose.
E allo stesso tempo, però,
dobbiamo imparare ad avere pazienza,
perdonatemi il gioco di parole.
Ricordandoci che le cose belle
e importanti della vita
non avvengono in un giorno.
Il vero amore, la vera amicizia,
o il - non so, in questo caso
il successo lavorativo e la carriera.
La pazienza è un'abitudine
e in quanto tale dobbiamo allenarla.
Come si allena la pazienza?
Come facciamo ad allenare questa pazienza?
Ricominciamo a porci le giuste domande.
Ricominciamo a darci degli obiettivi
nel lungo periodo.
Avendo però la capacità di spezzettarlo
in tanti piccoli obiettivi,
il famoso "divide et impera".
Godendoci questi piccoli obiettivi,
godendoci questi piccoli
successi quotidiani,
e i relativi insuccessi quotidiani.
Godendoci il processo, il percorso.
Proviamo a cambiare la narrativa.
Iniziamo a parlare di risultati
invece che di successo.
Perché se volessimo fare
una metafora sportiva,
non stiamo correndo i 100 metri,
stiamo correndo una maratona!
Stiamo correndo una maratona.
E una volta che abbiamo capito questo,
io credo che la chiave del successo,
o meglio, forse dovremmo dire
la chiave per i risultati,
Credo che sia veramente facile.
Perché chi cerca
la gratificazione istantanea,
quando non la ottiene abbandona la gara.
Ed è lì che si vede la differenza.
Perché in un contesto dove il 99%
delle persone abbandonano la gara,
vince chi ha pazienza!
Grazie dell'attenzione.
(Applausi)